America may sleep better at night if the
president proved his brain's all right
so Nikki Haley wants to be extra
cautious and make sure there's no
senility in the Oval Office
yeah Nikki Haley doubled down this week
on mandatory competency tests for
politicians older than 75 which is
pretty brave for someone who's Pastor
Prime
alignment but she points to Old Joe who
would be 82 on inauguration day if
re-elected but he's still sharpest
attack at least according to his
embalmer
and his doctors gave him the all clear
but that might have been for the
defibrillator
I had to say that eight times in my head
first and Nikki also calls out
California Senator Dianne Feinstein who
had 89 as a prime example of why we need
mental competency tests and maybe she
should take one assuming the smelling
salts ever kick in
but damn's no brain dead candidates are
very popular with dead voters and her
brain hasn't worked since I had a rat
tail mullet
hell Diane was in that sharp in her 60s
when she hired a Chinese spy to be her
driver
but is this about transparency and the
fact that Republicans and Democrats
deserve to know whether the people they
say to DC are at the top of their game
this is about transparency this is about
the fact that Republicans and Democrats
deserve to know whether the people they
send to DC are at the top of their game
these competency tests are very simple
they're just about naming things that
start with the same letter it's about
what month it is it's about what day it
is quick cat what month and day is it
it's uh today's Wednesday and it's May
3rd
back
your president I
have four time zones in the past five
days that was pretty good yeah very good
all right but such tests don't thrill
Biden's nurse Doctor Jill
by the way Jill is a doctor in the same
way Elvis was a black belt in karate
I'm glad we found the picture a few
weeks ago she body slammed Nikki's
proposal at least she didn't call her a
breakfast taco
but I wonder would her husband ever take
one of those
would your husband ever take one of
those
I mean we haven't even discussed we
would never even discuss something like
that of course you'd never discuss it
with him he has the slightest idea who
she is
it would be like talking to a potato
a doctor potato
so what say you Joe
hey hey no no look
look that lady Jill doesn't know what
she's talking about all right we never
discussed that
just ask my wife Nikki Haley what'd she
say I don't need one of those but I I'll
take the same one that the other guy
took I don't care remember that one the
uh
person woman
man
camera
TV repeat that back person radio
record player
photo photograph
my wife's a doctor you know the thing
done look
put that in your pipe and stuff it down
and beat me behind a five and dime Jack
thank you
Haley wouldn't it be great if publicly
because we know it's going to be Trump
versus Joe to have them both do
competency tests on TV and then put
compare them that would be fun I mean I
heard president Trump so many times talk
about taking one of these tests it was
so funny to watch them talk about I mean
the guys clearly competent Beyond bounds
like knew what he's doing with it in
command unlike Joe Biden but like look I
never thought I would have agreeing with
Bernie Sanders on my bingo card today
Bernie Sanders talked about letting the
American people make that determination
and look he's kind of right because it
doesn't take a rocket scientist to look
at Joe Biden and say this guy's not
competent he shakes hands with air he
grew up next to polish immigrants in the
Puerto Rican Community where he took out
a gang leader named uh Corn Pop after he
was a professor after he was a truck
driver and after he was arrested in the
Civil Rights Movement the guy's not
competent doesn't take a rocket
scientist and by the way how do you
enforce it we're not going to amend the
Constitution for this they're
voluntarily going to take the competency
test and test step aside if they fail I
don't think so yeah yeah Harlan are you
are you would you would you pass a
competency test I wouldn't no no no no
no
I didn't even pass my pap smear so let's
go
[Applause]
there is God that's what those were a
smoked one
but uh you know this guy forget a
competency test just this competency is
a big word you know how in every kid's
coloring book there's that one page
where you connect the dots and it it
makes like a happy narwhal coming out of
the ice I'd like to see Joe connect the
dot I mean this is the kind of guy you
could give him a Rubik's Cube that's one
color and he won't be able to solve it
all right I want to take that guy to
Cracker Barrel and have him do the
Little Triangle Peg thing and if he wins
he can be the president of omelettes how
about that
one color Rubik's Cube off to it and
still try to cheat like Mr President the
same color yeah
that thinks uh 7-Eleven stores should be
called 18.
[Applause]
too soon
no he had he had he actually liked
7-Elevens because there were Indian
people there remember
yeah remember
yeah all the why do all the Indian
people work at 7-Eleven wasn't that him
it was yeah it was him yeah it also was
him was like if you don't vote for me
you're not black yes apparently this
weekend we're all boys in the white
house so he's had a real fun Stellar
80th week this week so unless I don't I
think it's funny is his wife is so
defensive over it because I mean because
then we'd find out she's pulling the
strings I think it should be Case by
case because just like you take we don't
have to be Aegis Greg let's take the 80s
out there's enough of us in this room
who know a couple people in their 20s
one's real sharp the other one not so
much and if you put that dumb ass in any
job they'll ruin it yeah but you raise
them both the same ones ends up doing
well and the other one works at
McDonald's it's the same thing with 80
year olds you take an 80 year old that's
got his stuff together they can do great
things like President Trump has his
stuff together yeah Joe Biden does not
but then again he doesn't have to let's
be he's all our presidents too and if he
wants to live and make believe land it's
his right it's America so if he wants to
battle corn up for his eight moms of
different racial backgrounds good for
him live in fantasy world so you don't
have to remember yes that's true you
just make up new stuff as he goes cat
would you support this test for people
younger than 75. no I just I feel like
we already know like everyone said that
he's not competent and I would never
agree to take this test well I disagreed
with Bernie when he said how many 30
year olds could travel to Poland get on
the train go nine more hours go to meet
go to Ukraine meet with president
zielinski
everyone everyone
right especially the way he does it it's
like he gets there and he's like where
do I go to buy my ticket
that's true like it's the easy and so
many weight like being the president is
obviously very very hard but it's also
the easiest difficulty setting in terms
of having to do daily life tasks which
is where I struggle the most honestly
right you have other people do that for
you my my cat could do that yeah it's
true it's like he never had a heart
problem he can't fly but if he didn't
yes but he could never he never has to
look at a train schedule no he's gonna
be like oh should I use my points for
this or should I you know lose my ma
yeah where do I go to get the tickets
and like okay yeah he doesn't have to
figure anything out he doesn't he wakes
up every morning he has no idea what
he's doing that day Ollie he just knows
he's gonna wait for people to tell him
what he's doing that day I would love
that one that is a great life really
it's just like being a dog not to
mention everybody he works with is old
No One's Gonna sign up for that yeah
it's the entire poster board right there
was like a combined age of 900. yeah
nobody like no we get to die in this job
look
all right we got to move on up next a
drag Diva endorses joining the Armed
Forces hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else